[Musik]
mit ihrem markenzeichen dem pagenkopf
und dunkler sonnenbrille beherrscht anna
winter das 300 milliarden dollar schwere
amerikanische mode
anna ist der einflussreichste mensch in
der modewelt
als chefredakteurin der vogue wurde sie
selbst zu einer berühmtheit mit dem ruf
einer winters anerkennung ist wichtig
für alles was ich tue und eines
feuerspuckenden drachen für andere ich
habe nahm gehört wie eiskönigin oder
nuklearer winter aber um ergebnisse zu
erzielen musste anspruchsvoll sein ist
sie ein wahrer sanfter mensch nein warum
sollte sie das sein
ihr einfluss ist über die saiten des
hochglanzmagazins hinausgewachsen sie
ist einen schrittmacher
sie ist die frau die mode international
und zum großen geschäft gemacht hat
ich weiß nichts über mode und ich lese
die vogue nicht regelmäßig aber ich weiß
eine menge über sie anna winter stellte
sich ohne umschweife ihren
sagenumwobenen ruf einem ihrer seltenen
fernsehauftritte
ich habe diese woche in der new york
times gelesen dass ich eine eiskönigin
bin ich bin der sonnenkönig ich bin ein
alien aus dem district 9 und eine domina
also ich schätze das macht mich zu einer
lauwarmen adeligen aus dem all mit einer
peitsche
was denken sie guter auftritt
[Applaus]
ihr auftritt ist der der chefredakteurin
der politik 22 jahre lang hat die
mächtige und einschüchternde
bienenkönigin frauen gesagt was und wen
sie zu tragen haben lange röcke oder
kurze royal oder marineblau oder was
traue das neue schwarz ist ich bete mode
an ich bete an was sie über frauen sagt
die vogue ist anerkannt wie kein anderes
magazin und das ist unglaublich
befriedigend
anna ist revolutionär sie hat die ganze
mode industrie revolutioniert
anna ist jemand der mit konkurrenzdenken
umgeht in einer weise wie das jeder
machen sollte sie wird nicht wütend sie
will
management managed ihr medien profil mit
viel sorgfalt und lehnte es ab an
unserem programm teilzunehmen
[Musik]
hannah montana schon als junge frau
ehrgeizig 1949 in london geboren verließ
sie in den 60er jahren die schule und
war fasziniert von der londoner
gesellschaft und kultur
ihre mutter eleonore amerikanerin und
ihr britischer vater charles war der
abgebrühte chefredakteur der londoner
zeitung evening standard laurie
scheckter begann ihre karriere als anna
winters assistentin
sie wuchs mit einem journalisten auf
einem zeitungsmann beherrschte einige
bizarre standard eine strenge die sich
sicherlich auf sie ausgewirkt hat und so
geht sie nun noch alles an
als sie 20 war bekam winter ihren gut
bekleideten fuß in die tür beim gerade
gegründeten britischen magazin hafen
queen sie war außerordentlich eifrig sie
holte sich die besten fotografen um die
leiter hoch zu klettern aber nach fünf
jahren bei hp sind queen wurde sie bei
der wahl eines neuen chefredakteurs
übergang sie
verließ das magazin und england und
machte sich
1975 auf dem weg zur seventh avenue in
new york
sitzt an der spitze ihres eigenen
modeunternehmens und kennt winter seit
über 30 jahren
sie war nicht anna wintour die
hohepriesterin der vogue sie war meine
freundin und wir waren zwei mädchen die
versuchten etwas in der modeindustrie in
gang zu bringen
anna war definitiv darauf aus in
zeitschriften geschäft zu gehen und vor
allem zur vogue
aber die vogue musste noch warten ihren
ersten job in new york hatte winter bei
harper's bazar und wurde gefeuert weil
sie wie sie in einem zeitungsinterview
sagt zu europäisch war
nach ein paar monaten ohne arbeit nahm
sie ein jobangebot vom herausgeber des
penthouse magazins pop juni an als
moderedakteurin bei viva einem
erotikmagazin für frauen ihre models
gewannen an anerkennung ein paar jahre
später bekam sie ihren ersten großen job
mode redakteurin beim new york
sie war ein totales rätsel ein
faszinierendes rätsel sie trug diese
dunkle sonnenbrille so ziemlich die
ganze zeit es hieß schwimm oder sinken
sie sagte was sie wollte aber nicht wie
du es machen sollst ich habe in zwei
wochen vier kilo verloren weil das die
ganze zeit zu gehen
winter erarbeitete sich einen ruf für
stilvolle layout und eine unerbittliche
arbeitsmoral
[Musik]
sie hatte eine sehr festgelegte
tagesordnung sie hatte den mut und den
schneid und intelligenz und die energie
um all das zu tun
es hat nicht lange gedauert bis die
manager bei conti nach seinem us- und
alexander lieberman auf sie aufmerksam
von florian war verlagsleiter der vogue
und kennt winter seit 30 jahren
dieser anfangszeit fühlte sich fast an
die in einem jungen hollywood studio und
herr newhouse und alex hatten einfach
diesen großartigen sinn nicht nur dafür
wie man ein magazin hochzieht sondern
auch für die persönlichkeiten wie diese
magazine leiten sollten die organisation
hat leute mit einer vision und mit
entschlossenheit und tatkraft wirklich
mit offenen armen begrüßt niemand hatte
mehr tatkraft als anna winter sie wurde
mit einem job bei der vogue belohnt der
nur für sie geschaffen würde es war
nicht der job den sie sich gewünscht
hatte den hatte bereits die langjährige
chefredakteurin
es gab offensichtlich widerstand aber
sein anna hereinkommt ist sie kein
mauerblümchen ob macht ihren standpunkt
klar und deshalb wurde sie dort hin
bei mirabella nicht gut in ihrer
autobiografie bezeichnete sie die neue
kreativdirektorin als kalte und
misstrauische person die immer gegen sie
arbeitet
untergraben sie schrieb dass sie das
gefühl habe dass winter darauf
vorbereitet wurde ihren job zu
übernehmen
ich glaube es gab welche die sich
bedroht fühlten sie kannten sie nicht
sie wussten nicht genau warum sie hier
war und sie würden nicht jeden neuen
einfach so willkommen heißt
ganz zu schweigen von jemandem wie anna
die eine ziemlich gute figur machte und
definitiv die aufmerksamkeit der großen
entscheidungsträger von kontinent auf
sich zu
[Musik]
nach einem dreijährigen machtkampf legte
conde nast einen ozean zwischen sehen
sie boten winter eine beförderung zur
chefredakteurin der britischen vogue an
ein weiterer schritt auf der
karriereleiter der mit hohem
persönlichen kosten verbunden war schlug
horst winter zog mit ihrem baby nach
london während ihr mann in new york
1986 kam sie nach london und begann
sofort das erscheinungsbild der
britischen burg zu verändern
in gewisser weise machte sie so
bodenständig aber für leute die auf der
suche nach dingen waren die sie auch
kaufen konnten und sie machte das
magazin nutzerfreundlicher den lesern
malz diese abwechslung gefallen haben
aber ihre mitarbeiter waren nicht sehr
begeistert sie gaben ihr einen
spitznamen der blieb nuklearer winter
es ist ein bisschen dass greta garbo
ding wenn man nicht viel sagt und die
leute nicht einbindet aber das führt
dazu dass sich der rest der welt selbst
überlegt was wohl sache ist
ist sie warm und sanft nein warum sollte
sie
ist die jemand dessen meinung man gerne
hätte absolut nach 18 monaten holte
condé nast den aufstrebenden star zurück
nach new york um ihr einrichtungs
magazin haus im garten zu überholen
winter änderte den titel in die erste
bilder von leeren räumen gegen üppige
fotostrecken von
manche leser empörten sich und die
zeitschrift war gezwungen abos zurück zu
erstatten wollte terry war damals
dienstälteste mode redakteurin beim wall
street journal und autorin des buches
das ende der mode
deshalb nenne ich ein revolutionär weil
sie in so ein etabliertes magazin
einsteigt uns so etwas radikales tut die
gefahr dass man scheitert ist so hoch
wenn man etwas mutiges macht
andere karrieren wären von solchen
misserfolgen beendet worden doch nicht
die anna winter kontinent hatte noch
andere pläne mit ihr es war das am
schlechtesten gehütete geheimnis in der
modewelt es gab gerüchte dass wintour
chefredakteurin der amerikanischen vogue
werden und die veteranin grace mirabelle
ersetzen würde nun die heiße story ist
dass das wohl auch passieren wird nach
17 jahren
die 38 jährige anna winter bekam den job
ging sie immer wollte ihre vision war
von ihrem ersten cover an klar sie
kombinierte einen 10.000 dollar oberteil
mit einer 40 dollar jeans
das war etwas neues revolutionäres das
war eine neue herausgeberin sie war
brittany basti voll sie war jung und sie
hatte einen standpunkt wir wussten dass
das eine neue ära sein würde in einem
interview im dezember 88 erklärte winter
was es heißt die chefredakteurin der
vogue zu sein ich denke das wichtigste
in diesem job ist den richtigen instinkt
und das richtige bauchgefühl zu haben um
ein magazin zu produzieren das aus dem
moment heraus geboren wird das einfach
einfängt was sie jetzt gerade passiert
man muss mitten drin sein
[Musik]
mirabel us traditionelle titel bilder
wurden durch winters frischen neuen look
ersetzt
sie scheute keine kosten für aufwändige
shootings mit den besten fotografen
[Musik]
er wusste genau wie sie unserem wunsch
nach flucht und schönheit und echter
mode verbindet und mit dem bedürfnis
nach den dingen die uns frauen wichtig
sind dinge die zu unserem lebensstil
passen wer wir sind und wo wir herkommen
wieder einmal erkannte unter die
anziehungskraft von promis und ersetzte
supermodels durch superstar dem cover
filmemacher
winter hat sehr früh erkannt dass die
macht der prominenten globale industrie
und die mode zusammenkamen
wir hatten die mega marken gucci prada
airways berufstätige frauen übernahmen
führungspositionen also brauchten sie
power kleidung für die arbeit
sie verstand den glamour der top mode
den wunsch die menschen träumen nach
etwas streben zu lassen sie zu
inspirieren
aber sie verstand auch wie sich die mode
als geschäfts verändert hat
[Musik]
winters steigendes ansehen führte zu
steigenden werbeeinnahmen ätna dosa war
herausgeber der modezeitschrift
das werbegeschäft kann sehr launisch
sein sie müssen im laufe der zeit
loyalität aufbauen sie müssen den
werbetreibenden einen echten mehrwert
und gründeten um konsequent in ihren
publikationen zu bleiben weil es eine
der wettbewerbsfähigsten branche der
welt ist
innerhalb von zehn jahren stiegen die
werbeeinnahmen von knapp über 87
millionen dollar auf fast 150 millionen
dollar der erfolg der vogue brachte
winter wachsenden einfluss
ihre auftritte in den ersten reihen der
modeschauen mit ihrer dunklen
sonnenbrille erhielten eine ganz neue
bedeutung
jeder eilige gesichtsausdruck wurde nach
hinweisen durchsucht
[Musik]
wurde ein wichtiger show erst wenn sie
da war es wie eine bestätigung dass
deine show cool ist eine große sache
unter winter verwandelte sich die rose
vom magazin zur marke
der erfolg rückte auch sie in den
öffentlichen
1999 berichteten die boulevardzeitungen
über ihre scheidung und ihre beziehung
zum texanischen telekom
die leute traten und spekulierten über
jede ihrer bewegungen aber sie hat es im
grunde genommen ignoriert und ich glaube
das war klug
ungestört richtete winter ihre
aufmerksamkeit auf das was der rose
vorstand ihre antwort war ausnahmslos
dieselbe die leute fragen immer war das
ihre lieblings kollektion war dass ihre
lieblingsaufgabe aber für mich ist es
immer die nächste das was kommt es ist
immer die zukunft die meisten redakteure
denken nicht über ihren titel hinaus
aber renner denkt über die welt nach und
wie sie den titel beeinflusst und auch
darüber wie der titel die welt
beeinflussen kann tanzen ist ist charles
townes früherer präsident des kontinents
sie kennt alle aspekte des marketing sei
es die vermarktung der marke für den
verbraucher oder für die werbepartner
es geht um politischen einfluss um
sozialen einfluss sie positioniert die
marke mit blick auf all diese parameter
um die marke zu erweitern brachte sie
2003 die teen vogue heraus gefolgt von
demenz burg und der vogue living
innerhalb eines jahres sanken jedoch die
werbeeinnahmen für die mensch burg um
über eine million dollar
2008 fünfte kontinent das magazin auf
eine gelegentliche beilage die vogue
living verschwand komplett
die markenerweiterung hatte am ende
nicht funktionierte war aber trotzdem
ein produktives experiment sie geht
risiken ein sie arbeitet wirklich sehr
hart wenn es nicht funktioniert dann
schiebt sie es beiseite erholt sich und
versucht einfach aus der sache zu lernen
und weiterzumachen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
winters erhöhte sichtbarkeit und ihre
öffentliche unterstützung der
pelzindustrie führten zu selten
konfrontationen
auf dem höhepunkt der anti pelz bewegung
war anna sehr bestimmt sie trug ihre
pelze bau der strand brauchten bei der
chance auf
dias mittags im präsens und jemand das
tier auf den teller
ende durch paris läuft und jemand dich
mit pastete bewirft und dich
niederschlägt ist das ziemlich aggressiv
aber sie stand auf wischte sich das
gesicht ab ging zurück ins hotel zog
sich um und ging zum nächsten treffen
danach bekamen sie personenschutz wenn
sie eine show besuchte hat er sehe ich
diese beiden bodyguards dabei
das druck auch dass du bei diesem mythos
zu schüren das sie eine klasse für sich
sie steckte in ihrem stylischen
stilettos und ließ sich in ihre
unterstützung für die milliardenschwere
pelzindustrie möchte irgendwie berühmter
sie wurde desto mehr negative
aufmerksamkeit bekam der roman der
teufel trägt prada wurde von vielen in
der modebranche als schlecht getarnte
und vernichtende darstellung von winter
angesehen
die hollywood version mit meryl streep
war ein riesenerfolg und spielte
weltweit über 326 millionen dollar in
den kinos ein
[Musik]
dieser ruf des drachens wird oft
porträtiert ich glaube es gibt ja eine
agenda problem weil sie eine frau ist
erwarten die leute dass sie sich auf
eine bestimmte art und weise verhält
wenn sie eine firma leiten würde wäre
das überhaupt kein thema
winter war inzwischen eine anerkannte
größe mit weitreichenden beziehungen
sie hat auch anderen sehr großen marken
geholfen
wenn die nach einem designer oder einem
kreativdirektor suchten hat sie auch
diesen marken zum erfolg verholfen
eine marke die ihre hilfe brauchte waage
seit jahren wird das unternehmen unter
sinken
die konsultierten winter und sie im fall
den jungen designer
sie hat mich angerufen und ich hatte
auch schon darüber nachgedacht und sie
erklärte mir wie dieser job aussehen
könnte also wie sie sich das vorstellen
würde
sie war ein großartiger resonanzboden
als ich über den job nachgedacht habe
einer winters anerkennung wichtig für
alles was ich mache ist es immer noch
sie sieht bis heute alles was ich tue
aber nach vier jahren und glanzlose
ergebnisse and leave the star designer
winters interesse an der förderung neuer
talente lief aber nicht nach und sie
gründete den wunsch fand die stipendien
und unternehmen
man muss für nachwuchs sorgen dass war
anna sehr licht
das ist mehr designer gibt also auch
mehr werbung und mehr umsatz das ist
alles ein kreislauf
und so kamen 2007 börsen service und der
september ausgabe
das magazin hatte rekordverdächtige 7
127 seiten mit werbeanzeigen
die erfolgs dokumentation die
september-ausgabe gewährt einen seltenen
einblick in die modewelt mit der
anspruchsvollen frau
es ist wunderschön danach bin ich nicht
so verrückt
wie sie schwanger aus nein dieser
schnitt wirkt so groß
sieht aus wie für eine blinde
[Musik]
er schaut nicht zurück sie schaut nach
vorne sie verzweifelt nicht sie vertraut
sich selbst sie braucht eine dicke haut
aber auch unter einer dicken haut sind
nerven nerven aus stahl brauchte sie
durch die rezession sagen wir uns mit
wirtschaftlichen umständen konfrontiert
die wir nie für möglich gehalten hätten
[Musik]
2009 zwang die tiefste rezession seit
jahrzehnten
die unternehmen dazu werbegelder zu
kürzen
die anzeigen verkäufe der bus für die
wichtige september-ausgabe brachen ein
von 727 auf 429
kontinents ist ein privates unternehmen
das keine finanzergebnisse
veröffentlicht aus
aber ganz offensichtlich stammt das
unternehmen unter druck
wurden eingestellt hunderte von stellen
gestrichen
als aber auch in mode viertel von
manhattan der umsatz einbrach
ihre idee war ein weltweites verkauf 7
danke dass sie heute angekommen
das war ein beispielloses ereignis das
über 1000 einzelhändler auf der ganzen
welt zusammen brachte tausende und
abertausende von verbrauchern
überfluteten die geschäfte
das event war so erfolgreich dass es zu
einer jährlichen veranstaltung wurde wir
möchten uns bei euch allen für euer
kommen bedanken wie geht es euch heute
abend
winter sprang auch ein um einen der
schätze new yorks zu retten die kostüme
sammlung im metropolitan museum of art
als kopf einer spendenaktion moderierte
sie die jährliche benefiz gala
das war etwas das sogar mit den aus gas
konkurrierte
damals präsidentin des metropolitan
museum of art in dem jahr haben wir
durch ihre führung in einer nacht über
neun millionen dollar gesammelt mitten
in einer rezession und es lagen noch
weitere gewaltige herausforderungen frau
winter kontinent hatte sich nur langsam
an das digitale zeitalter angepasst
jetzt hängen winters zukunft und die der
vogue davon ab
jeden monatszeitschrift muss wirklich
prüfen ob bedarf an schnellen
informationen besteht und die decken
sind diese nachfrage
ihr monatlich erscheinendes magazin
sieht sich zunehmender konkurrenz durch
blogger und interaktive websites
ausgesetzt das gab designern eine neue
plattform um ihre entwürfe direkt zu
präsentieren und gleichzeitig ihre
produkte zu verkaufen ohne sich auf
hochglanz fotostrecken in der vogue zu
verlassen
winter teilte sich nun die begehrte
erste reihe mit den neuen medien
ich garantiere ihnen dass anna das spiel
der digitalen inhalte verändern wird
wir bringen markeninhalte mit ihrer
stimme zu millionen von verbrauchern die
wir mit einem magazin als einzige medium
unmöglich erreichen können
[Musik]
und dass kollegen wie auch ihre kritiker
glauben dass sie über die
[Musik]
männer macht fast jeden tag etwas das
ist enorm sie hat immer ideen wie man
diese branche voran bringen sie immer
weiter vorantreiben kann
diese industrie ist mehrere hundert
milliarden dollar schwer und das ist
vielleicht nur ein nebenprodukt von
vielen aber eines davon ist anders
leitung des mode magazins für mehr als
20 jahre
sie hat dieses unglaubliche gefühl dafür
was gute mode was talent und kreativität
sind dvds
sie ist nicht hier nur um zu sagen ob
ein kleid schön ist oder nicht oder ob
ein neuer schuh groovig genug ist sie
ist da um die gesamte branche zu
ermutigen
nachwuchstalente etablierte talente für
alle ist es schwer im rennen zu bleiben
aber sie sieht das als ihre pflicht an
das ist auch ihr vermächtnis sie ist die
frau die mode wirklich in das big
business und in die welt gebracht hat
[Musik]
[Applaus]
er ist die regierende supermacht der
mode in unserer branche sieht jeder
ralph lauren als vorbild an ein traum
fabrikant der milliarden verdiente indem
er sich vorstellte was andere sich
letzten jedes mal wenn nicht kleidungen
mache ich ein ich glaube seit walt
disney war niemand so erfolgreich darin
millionen und abermillionen von menschen
für seine fantasien zu begeistern
ralph lauren strahlt eine aura des
gehobenen lebenshaus als marke steht für
klassische zeitlose
die marke ist ihre erinnerung an diesen
fabelhaften lebensstil aber sein leben
war nicht so perfekt ich glaube er
dachte das wäre das letzte mal dass er
den falschen weg eingeschlagen hat das
war es aber nicht bei weitem wir haben
immer gescherzt dass er immer den plan
hatte die welt zu übernehmen er hat die
welt übernommen daran besteht kein
zweifel
[Musik]
ralph lauren ist die berühmteste ein
mann marke des planeten eine marke die
synonym für einen überlegenen lebensstil
estrel wusste immer dass er nicht
gewinnen würde wenn er keine risiken
eingeht und er geht immer an die grenzen
erhält sich nachts wach er hat angst er
könnte versagen er ist besessen brillant
unberechenbar und schwierig aber er kann
auch nett und interessant und süß sein
er ist ein bündel von widersprüchen
lohan besteht darauf dass die bilder von
ihm seine geschichte erzählen und wollte
nicht an unserem programm teilnehmen
bevor er ralph lauren war war er
wallflex schätzt das jüngste von vier
kindern dass die kleider des bruders
auftrug 1939 als sohn jüdischer
einwanderer aus der arbeiterklasse
geboren wuchs
sein vater war amateur künstler wie wenn
man mit jemandem zusammenlebt für den
ästhetik wichtig ist hat das
auswirkungen auf das kind in diesem
haushalt das
wirkliche leben
er ging zur ja shiva und trug eine kippa
und alle anderen utensilien orthodoxer
juden jeden tag
er erzählte mir dass er ganz am anfang
als er in der bronx lebte ins kino ging
und sich buchstäblich in die fantasien
der filme dieser ära stürzte die
wirklich eine der großen kino epochen
der späten 40er und frühen 50er jahre
war
das ding ist einer der jugend
wir alle haben als kinder auf die
kinoleinwände geguckt und auch die
schauspieler wie gut sie aussahen reif
mochte vor allem fred astaire
und er hat sich wirklich in die szenen
hinein versetzt in denen männer wie gary
cooper und cary grant spielten er sieht
die figuren die seine träume und seine
visionen bevölkern und diese vision
diese fähigkeit in eine fantasiewelt
einzutauchen hat wolf in die modebranche
mitgebracht
in einem der beiden einzigen großen
fernseh interviews die er je gegeben hat
erzählte loren 1993 charlie rose von den
auswirkungen dieser erfahrung
ich wurde sehr von filmen beeinflusst
von einer welt die einen sinn für träume
hatte einen sinn für etwas anderes
und was mich an diesen orten
beeinflusste war der good guy der cowboy
nicht der kitschige kehrmann auf dem
weißen pferd
mein gefühl war ich hatte eine
integrität an die ich glaubte ich hätte
es wirklich
aber ich hatte einen standpunkt ich war
sehr stark
warum hältst ihn erzählt dass lauren
hält den vater einen schneider als
teenager darum bat ihm einen seiner
ersten anzüge zu machen ich erinnere
mich dass ich mit ihnen zu meinem vater
ging und er sehr schwierig war ich sagte
zu meinem vater papa ach was er will er
sagte ich kann es ihm nicht recht machen
und ich sagte okay das war's auch wenn
er ein perfektionist war laurien war ein
mann für alle fälle er mochte basketball
am liebsten würde ich sagen alles gut
wie geht es ihnen als oprah winfrey ihn
auf seiner ranch in colorado interviewte
erzählte laurin von seinen frühesten
ambitionen wollten sie schon immer ein
cowboy sein wollte baseballspieler
werden ich wollte schauspieler werden
tänzer werden eigentlich wollte ich
batman werden dass das geheimnis dass
ich im verraten da draußen
als teenager entschieden er und sein
bruder jerry sich für eine
namensänderung adolf sagte zu mir das
problem mit dem namen widgets ist dass
er das wort center und er musste endlose
hänseleien über sich ergehen lassen die
sich durch die ganze schulzeit zogen und
auch in der armee rolf schlug mir vor
dass der name laurin verloren bekommt
die eine große stilikone und
schauspielerin war nach
der highschool arbeitete loren als
verkäufer abends besuchte er wirtschaft
einen abschluss gemacht 1964 nach einem
kurzen abstecher in die armee heiratete
der 26 jährige lauren ricky rubio eine
empfangsdame die er in einer art praxis
kennen gelernt hatte er heiratete das
mädchen das im cabrio perfekt außer mit
ihren blonden haaren ricky wurde sein
model seinen rückhalt ricky war glaube
ich immer in seinem hinterkopf
immer noch auf der suche nach seinem
platz in der welt wandte sich lauren der
new yorker mode branche zu er wurde
verkäufer bei brooke crothers und dann
bei einer reihe von krawatten
herstellern
ich nahm ihn zu seinem ersten ko spiel
in glattbrugg mit wo wir all diese
fabelhaften dinge sahen
silber leder werde die großen schlanken
blondinen großen hüther
einfach eine high society von der wir
nichts was
diese fabelhafte welt verwandelte lorenz
vision er rief mich an und sagte er
wolle sich selbstständig machen und was
ich von dem namen halten würde er sagte
er denkt an players polo und ich sagte
ralf hohl o ist elitär
kaum jemand weiß etwas darüber aber
jeder spielt also hast du keine wahl es
muss players sein sagte ok vielen dank
und der rest ist geschichte
es war die ära der einfarbigen schmalen
krawatten als lauren etwas radikales
vorschwebt bunte breite krawatten
er machte sich selbstständig eine seiner
ersten stationen bloomingdale's marvin
tram war damals ceo und präsident von
blooming 11 kurz vor seinem tod sprach
er über den forschen jungen designer
er zeigte sie dem krawatten einkäufer
von bloomingdale's der sagte gefallen
mir die kaufe aber
ich will nicht dass
ich will ein blumen- und
das macht er darum kämpfte einen auftrag
von blumen zu bekommen er machte den
koffer zu und sagte ohne meinen namen
will ich den auftrag nicht
[Musik]
einige monate nachdem ralph lauren das
angebot von bloomingdale's ausgeschlagen
hatte rief ihn das renommierte
unternehmen zurück ich fand die
krawatten großartig und wenn er seinen
namen drauf haben wollte war das okay
ich war sicher dass sich die krawatten
verkaufen würden und das werden sie auch
andere bekannte namen in der herren
bekleidungsbranche wollten auch
mitmachen wie broistedt und nehmen
markus innerhalb eines jahres verkaufte
laurin krawatten für eine halbe million
dollar
und er hatte noch größeres vor
seiner marke zu erweitern er wollte das
tun indem er sich kleidung vorstellte
die er selbst tragen würde
du dachtest du kannst in england kaufen
was cary grant ruck dass fred astaire
trug aber du konntest nicht in ein
geschäft gehen und es kaufen als ich kam
war das geschäft überhaupt nicht so die
sachen die ich macht und über nicht
kaufen und konnte sie nicht finden
bloomingdales sah das potenzial und den
profit in lawrence linie
arbeiteten eng zusammen von krawatten
über herrenhemden bis hin zu anzügen
sportjacken rosen die ganze kollektion
und dann kam uns sagte marvin ich will
eine damenkollektion machen
der wichtigste durchbruch für ralph
lauren war wahrscheinlich dass er eine
eigene boutique bei bloomingdale's bekam
das war der moment wo jemand außerhalb
seiner phantasiewelt ihn zustürmte und
ihn in die geschäftswelt einführte
es war das erste mal dass bloomingdale's
einem designer eine eigene boutique im
geschäft gehabt
und das geschäft wuchs sehr schnell ich
wusste genau was er im laden wollte was
er auf den etagen wollte und was er an
den wänden wollte es entstand ein
richtiges ralph lauren umfeld
wenn man sich die 60er und 70er jahre
ansieht da wurde kleidung auf
schaufensterpuppen gepackt sie haben die
geschichten erzählt rolf nahm dich in
eine fantasiewelt mit auf eine insel in
die hamptons in den wilden westen
drei jahre nach dem verkauf seiner
ersten krawatten gewann lauren 1970 den
oscar der modebranche den codie award
für seine menswear linie und 1971 kaufte
lorenz das erste von vielen luxusautos
der pulitzer-preis architektur und
design kritiker paul goldberger hat über
rolf lorenz berühmte autosammlung
berichtet ich glaube es war ein mercedes
cabrio dass er sich zu diesem zeitpunkt
nicht ganz leisten konnte er kaufte es
trotzdem weil er genau diese art von
aufstreben verstand die er anderen
leuten zu verkaufen versuchte
er griff auch seine frühere fantasie
zurück das polospiel und führte sein
logo ein um den polo spieler aber trotz
des starken umsatzes geriet das
unternehmen in finanzielle
schwierigkeiten
laurin war gezwungen den größten teil
seiner persönlichen ersparnisse zu
investieren 100000 dollar er stellte
auch einen neuen geschäftspartner ein
den einzelhandels manager peter strohm
der einsprang und zehn prozent des
unternehmens für 6000 dollar kaufte ich
glaube er war sehr besorgt sie lieferten
alles zu spät ihr vertriebs muster war
völlig falsch
wir lösten diese probleme und brachten
die richtigen leben dazu die richtige
menge zu kaufen und alles richtig zu
präsentieren
zwei jahre später wieder auf dem
richtigen weg bekam lorenz marke einen
aufschwung weil seine männer kleidung im
großen gatsby mit spielte seine
fähigkeit kleider zu entwerfen die wie
kostüme aussagen die wie kleider
aussagen die die kostüme aussahen war
unvergleichlich
wichtiger war der annie hall look
inspirierte eine der ersten damen
kollektion
und der designer selbst war auf das
haupt model in den werbekampagnen
seiner marke
hat auf vielen seiner modenschau
fotografiert er
trägt diese sachen
mit seinen jüngern wissen sie ralf in
seinen kleidern das war authentisch
das unternehmen brachte eine reihe neuer
kollektionen heraus darunter auch eine
umfangreiche haushalts kollektion laurin
lizenzierte seinen namen auch für andere
produkte und tauschte damit kontrolle
gegen kapital ein
1986 ging ralph lauren aufs ganze und
gab 30 millionen dollar aus um einen
eigenständigen flagship store zu
eröffnen
in der historischen rheinländer menschen
in new york
meine frau und ich waren dort am
eröffnungstag um 14 uhr und der laden
war voll und ich sagte ralf wie geht es
dir
er sagte ich glaube es geht mir gut wie
gesagt du bist einzelhändler du kannst
jetzt die kasse klingeln lassen und der
manager sagte wir haben 41.000
eingenommen fragte das gut ich sagte das
ist sehr gut dann ging ich zurück in
mein büro und das telefon klingelte
gegen
marvin wir haben hunderttausend dollar
wie es das und ich sagte es ist
großartig
er lernte einzelhändler zu sein
das hat der welt seine geschichte
erzählt jeder der nach new york kommt es
ist ja sogar im thorberg von new york
man versteht ralph lorenz botschaft wenn
man dort durch geht schon wenn man an
diesen fenstern vorbei kommt als das
unternehmen weiter wuchs setzte lorenz
seine mitarbeiter mehr denn je unter
druck
es gibt ein riesiges team von designern
und kreativen führungskräften sie
entwerfen machen alles aber bringen es
zur auf und rolf ist es der entscheidet
es gibt da diese erstaunlichen teile
kleine aufkleber die auf den tafeln
angebracht werden da steht drauf
und mit diesem brief loren die kleider
die designs in besitz und verdient die
anerkennung
reife achtet mehr auf die details als
jeder andere den ich in meiner allen
getroffen habe und wenn er entwirft ein
sich die kleider an sieht schaut dahin
und will ein reh wer das noch viel
spitze ist schmal
geplant ist es größer sein
1986 hatte das unternehmen einen
geschätzten wert von 600 millionen
dollar und laurin selbst war das
titelbild nicht seine modelle es schien
als könnte das leben für ihn nicht
besser werden als er seine nächste damen
kollektion heraus brachte aber hinter
den kulissen wurde der designer von
etwas alarmierendem erschüttert
wir waren oben im century das hotel das
finale der show
reif kam raus und ich sein gesicht wie
ich noch nie gesehen hatte ich sah dass
er mit den tränen kämpfte ich fing an zu
weinen
irgendetwas ging da vor sich ich wusste
nicht mal was es war es war einfach in
tüten
nur die menschen die ihm am nächsten
standen wussten dass bei laurent ein
hirntumor festgestellt worden war
es war eines dieser dinge die man
einfach nicht glauben konnte die rave
nicht passieren konnten was bedeutet das
für die zukunft es gab damals so viele
fragen
[Musik]
als ich im taxi nach hause fuhren in den
nachrichten hörte dass der designerin
für eine gehirn operation eingeliefert
wurde
aber ja mein gott
natürlich habe ich mir sorgen gemacht er
tat mir so leid wissen sie
zum glück war der tumor gutartig
nach der operation lag ein langer weg
vor ihm und neue prioritäten
ich glaube nicht dass er sich sorgen
darüber gemacht hat was mit dem geschäft
passiert er hat sich sorgen um das leben
gemacht teilte sein martyrium mit
charlie watts
ich weiß noch als ich aus dem
krankenhaus kam und im central park
spazieren ging
ich war sehr schwach er sah ich ein paar
jungs die im park rannten und schwitzten
und ich sagte zu mir das will ich auch
machen
einige wochen später kehrte laurin zur
arbeit zurück ich glaube er kam sogar
aggressiver zurück als je zuvor aber ich
glaube er war ein bisschen entspannter
ein bisschen gelassener und schätzte
vielleicht jeden moment ein bisschen
mehr
er brachte eine kollektion für fitness
kleidung heraus und entwarf ein
umsatzstarkes ba vergab millionen aus um
diese produktlinien zu fördern james
fällen redakteur von women's wear daily
bezeichnend war florian als ein
kraftpaket in der magazin welt weil er
einer der größten werbekunden ist wenn
ich mal ein paar auf den markt bringen
und eine anzeigenserie schalter machen
sie ein profil von mir gucken sie sich
mal die anzahl der magazine an die ihn
auf das cover gesetzt haben pulse sein
40-jähriges jubiläum hatte das spiegelt
das ausmaß wieder in dem sie seine
finanzielle unterstützung der letzten
jahren zu schätzen wüssten es zu
schätzen wussten und auch darauf
angewiesen waren ein jährlicher
werbeetat von 200 millionen dollar ist
ein 800 pfund schwerer gorilla ralph
lauren sitzt wo immer er will und wenn
das das cover ihres magazins ist dann
wird ralf dort sein
lorenz dominanz wurde auch deutlich als
audrey hepburn ihm den preis des
amerikanischen mode-designer rats für
sein lebenswerk überreicht das war eine
seiner muse
die frau die als kleines kind in den
filmen gesehen hat bereich team jetzt
diese statue für ihren der oscar hätte
sein können
erinnern sie sich an die prinzessin ich
habe sie mit der einführung von lorenz
lila label 1994 das unternehmen für das
ungeübte auge großartig aus schließlich
waren die umsätze so hoch wie nie aber
das war nur die halbe geschichte liga
prob acker ist einzelhandels
journalisten
wie jeder einzelhändler der große träume
hat wuchs ist einfach zu schnell es
wurde viel kapital aufgewendet um die
matte dorthin zu bringen wo er sie haben
wollte das in verbindung mit einem sehr
glanzlosen vertrieb schuf den perfekten
sturm für ein unternehmen das fast am
rande des bankrotts stand
lauren brauchte einen rettungsanker und
fand ihn bei goldman sachs die
investment firma kaufte 28 prozent von
polo ralph lauren für 135 millionen
dollar es war für uns überraschend weil
wir nicht wussten dass er finanziell so
weit mit dem rücken zur wand stand und
ich glaube das hat zu der goldman sachs
opposition geführt
sie sind sehr gut darin herauszufinden
welche unternehmen langfristiges
wachstum versprechen und genau das haben
sie bei ralph lauren gesehen die
finanzspritze führte zu einem
exponentiellen wachstum und polo ralph
lauren eröffnete neue läden und
renovierte ältere
1997 war ralph lauren der
meistverkauften designer der welt die
verbraucher gaben fast 5 milliarden
dollar pro jahr für seine produkte aus
goldman sachs sei noch größeres
potenzial und drängte ihn zum börsengang
doch er war nicht so sicher
er hatte immer bedenken dass er in eine
aktiengesellschaft weniger
handlungsfreiheit haben würde dass es
nicht mehr seine eigene marke war weil
er mit aktionären und einem vorstand zu
tun hatte
[Musik]
trotz seiner anfänglichen vorbehalte
beschloss valoren im juni 97 ob ein
unternehmen an die börse zu bringen
liszt daran einzelhandels analystin bei
macquarie capital beobachtet das
unternehmen seit ja
eine herausforderung bei einem
börsengang besteht darin dass die
investoren von quartal zu quartal von
jahr zu jahr ein sehr gleichmäßiges
wachstum sehen wollen und ich glaube
dass sie in den ersten tagen als
aktiengesellschaft damit zu kämpfen
hatten nach dem börsengang berichteten
wir über seine jahresversammlung der
stand vor den aktionären und sagte die
wallstreet versteht mich nicht unsere
anteilseigner sitzen nur da ich wünschte
sie würden verstehen was wir tun
laurin versuchte nun die aktionäre
zufrieden zu stellen er verkaufte im
meer leben aber das umsatzwachstum
verlangsamte sich und die gewinnmargen
gingen zurück der 16 monate nach dem
höchststand von 33 dollar pro aktie fiel
sie unter 17 dollar
ich weiß dass es ihm gequält hat wir
haben darüber gesprochen er war
frustriert dass die wall street nicht
das sehen konnte was ihm völlig klar war
und seit 1967 immer klar gewesen war
dass er es war dass er der mann war es
trieb ihn in den wahnsinn und in dieses
umfeld kam ein mann namens roger forrer
der einer der großen einzelhandels
manager amerikas war roger fahrer kam
und restrukturierte die und sexy teile
des geschäfts lieferkette betrieb und
dass er auch tat erkaufte die lizenzen
zurück er brachte diese marke zurück ins
haus und stellte sicher dass all diese
marken unter dem dach von ran
sie machten gerade eine enorme
wachstumsphase durch das etwas
zusammenstellen das die botschaft der
marken video in auftrag das mich
inspiriert das ist eine geschichte ein
thema das mich anspricht
besteht eine koalition nicht auf seinem
ärmel oder einem echten und stoff ich
entwerfe sie aus einem traum aus
kontrolle ist für ihn sehr wichtig und
auf diese weise konnten wir eine
einheitliche botschaft präsentieren er
musste nicht dabei sein aber es war als
wäre er dabei gewesen
so expandierte weiter mit blick auf den
internationalen absatz eröffnete er
flagship stores in mailand tokio und
sogar moskau
amerika wird in frankreich von
mcdonald's und ralph lauren
repräsentiert und ich meine was von
beidem lässt unsere kultur besser
aussehen ich glaube der ralph lauren
store ist so eine art symbolische
amerikanische botschaft aber im sommer
2012 wurde der designer angegriffen als
enthüllt wurde dass die von lauren
entworfenen olympia trikots nicht in den
usa hergestellt wurden made in china das
ist china china sie sollten alle
uniformen nehmen und schon brennen das
unternehmen versprach die trikots für
die winterspiele 2014 in den usa zu
produzieren
während seiner gesamten karriere
kultivierte ralph lauren sein eigenes
image sehr sorgfältig er hat wohnsitze
auf der fifth avenue in jamaica long
island von bedford new york und eine
17.000 hektar ranch in colorado wo er
zeit mit seiner frau und seinen drei
erwachsenen kindern verbringen und er
gibt viel zeit und geld für eine ganz
andere leidenschaft aus calls autos sind
spaß und sport sagt er und sie bieten
der eine ganz andere erfahrung für mich
arbeiten sie sehr hart dieses werbevideo
auf dem jahr 2010 kündigte eine pariser
ausstellung einiger seiner über 60
oldtimer an
er hat mir mal gesagt er sammelt vor
allem deshalb autos weil er sie einfach
liebt und sie zu ihm passen er sammelt
keine kunst im gegensatz zu den meisten
menschen in seiner einkommensklasse er
sagte man kann ein gemälde nicht fahren
und er liebt es eines seiner autos
zunehmen und damit an einem
sonntagnachmittag herumzufahren
paul goldberger sagt dass lohan bei
einigen seiner autos lief abel änderte
er sieht sich etwas an und sagt das ist
wunderbar und aufregend und schön aber
es könnte noch schöner sein und ich
möchte es noch perfekter machen
seit 40 jahren hat ralph lauren mit
seinem streben nach perfektion das
unternehmen das seinen namen trägt als
ceo und vorstandsvorsitzender fest im
griff
ich glaube das symbol mit dem polo pony
hat bestand es ist etwas das die kunden
über einen langen zeitraum gewählt haben
das ist wahrscheinlich die beste
geschichte in meiner berichterstattung
weil es so viele wachstumsmöglichkeiten
gibt mit denen sich der umsatz in den
nächsten jahren wohl mehr als verdoppeln
wird
der ehemalige krawatten verkäufer ist
mit 72 jahren einer der reichsten
menschen der welt und siebeneinhalb
milliarden dollar schwer ich glaube dass
das letzte stückchen ralf litz dass in
ihm geblieben ist ein kern von
unsicherheit ist und das ist der
treibstoff der den motor antreibt der
die person antreibt die diese marke
verkörpert
ralf ruht sich nicht eine minute lang
auf seinen lorbeeren aus ich meine man
kann den moment genießen aber man muss
verstehen dass man die dinge am laufen
halten muss man darf keine one trick
pony seien
in der höhe des efre 40 im herzen von
paris befindet sich der hauptsitz von
care in dem luxus giganten zu dem neben
gucci als hauptmarke auch auf samoa
bottega veneta und valencia gehören ein
meisterwerk von 1600 mit garten einem
17.000 quadratmeter großen gebäude und
einer kirche im inneren der gucci hat
befindet sich in der wir mit senate 79
in mailand
35.000 quadratmeter in einer ehemaligen
restaurierten flugzeug verbringen es
umfasst einen sechsstöckigen turm für
büros und designer einen showroom einen
raum für modeschauen und auch einen
wilden wald aber in der wir industrie a
19 in campino in diesem anonymen gebäude
zwischen der autobahn und dem
tennisplatz werden 80 prozent der
gewinne der gesamten klering gruppe
erzielt einen nettogewinn von 1,7
milliarden franken im jahr 2017
ein willkommen zu einer bande vor
energie
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nachdem sie 20 jahre lang über die lg in
campino steuern im tessin gezeigt hat
hat das unternehmen das zur kehring
gruppe gehört das finanzamt in den
ländern zurück erobert in denen die
arbeiter den reichtum produzieren dieses
jahr verlässt der größte steuerzahler
den kanton
lackum fährmann gemeinde campino hat
dies bestätigt hier machte das was alle
gutsche ihnen jährlich drei viertel der
steuereinnahmen aus
was genau hat ihnen lg im dezember wenn
ich mich nicht irre gesagt
november sie teilten uns mit dass wir
aufgrund einer änderung in ihrem
unternehmen in den nächsten jahren
weniger steuern erhalten würden
genau wie viel weniger
mir sagen wir im jahr 2009 10 80 prozent
weniger als er üblicher standard und ab
2020 dann 95 prozent weniger
was also bleibt sind nur fünf prozent
der einnahmen die bisher von lg bezahlt
wurden
grob gesagt ja
der konzern wird in der schweiz deutlich
weniger steuern zahlen und hat bereits
angekündigt vorerst 150 mitarbeiter zu
versetzen campino wird jedes jahr acht
millionen franken verlieren der kanton
sogar mehr als 20
hier ist der platz mit den steinen
granit oder was weiß ich und drumherum
wird die bepflanzung sein einschließlich
etwaiger dekoration des platzes pflanzen
und andere dinge
campino mit 1500 einwohnern bis heute
die reichste stadt des tessins ist das
symbol für die enormen einnahmen die der
luxus riese jährlich garantiert mit
diesem geld werden das neue gemeindehaus
und der platz fertig gestellt eine
investition von rund 10 millionen
franken
[Musik]
es ist wirklich groß war es eine
ungewöhnliche investition für eine stadt
mit 1500 einwohnern sobald sie das sind
große räume die platz für entwicklung
bieten als die lupe
möchten sie den wegfall der einnahmen
aus ihren wirtschaftlichen ressourcen
es hat die dinge ein bisschen verändert
früher waren wir onkel dagobert es war
nur so weil wir glück hatten und wir
wir haben die mittel gut verwaltet und
können sicherlich die nächsten fünf
jahre ohne probleme weiter machen
in diesen jahren hat ktm pilot 30
millionen franken beiseite gelegt die
ist der gemeinde nun ermöglichen das
schlimmste zu verhindern
[Musik]
das war muss ich sagen eine kalte dusche
nicht nur für die gemeinde sondern auch
für den kanton und folglich auch auf
bundesebene und ich denke wir haben kein
recht uns aus irgendeinem grund zu
beschweren
der umsatzrückgang bei alg ii worauf ist
das zurückzuführen
auf die umstrukturierung die sehne halb
des unternehmens hatten das ist die
veränderung die beziehungen die wir
hatten sind gut
wir sollten hier diskretion wahren denn
das unternehmen selbst hat auch immer
diskretion wahren lassen
heute wird jedoch gegen den konzern von
der staatsanwaltschaft mailand ermittelt
wonach er gerade über die tessiner
niederlassung lg luxury goods
international essay zwischen 2011 und
2017 steuern in höhe von 1,4 milliarden
euro hinterzogen und einnahmen in höhe
von 14,5 milliarden euro nicht
deklariert haben soll
der faktor wurde die tatsache dass gegen
sie wegen steuerhinterziehung ermittelt
wird von dem unternehmen bei ihrem
treffen erwähnt
nein wir haben nicht über untersuchungen
gesprochen auch weil es nicht an uns
liegt zu wissen oder nicht zu wissen
warum gegen sie ermittelt wird wenn
gegen sie ermittelt wird
aber wir haben von den zinsen profitiert
die sie uns gegeben haben und das ist
genug für uns ich persönlich habe nicht
zu beanstanden es tut mir leid dass
dieses geld woanders hingeht aber
solange sie hier waren hat sich niemand
das schwert denn es gab nur einen
verlust zu verzeichnen
die wälder auf kantonaler ebene bei den
steuern
haben sie sich jemals gefragt wie ein
unternehmen wie lg so viele gewinne in
krempin erzielen konnte
wir haben uns nie darum gekümmert wie
sie diese gewinne erzielt haben
der lge hauptsitz in krempin
erwirtschaftete 2017 einen reingewinn
von fast 1,7 milliarden franken zum
vergleich das ist ein höherer gewinn als
bei swisscom und doppelt so hoch wie bei
swatch wie wir bereits in einem bericht
von vor zwei jahren aufzeigten hat lg
mit nur 800 angestellten im vergleich zu
den 30.000 angestellten im rest der welt
seit jahren den größten teil der gewinne
des multinationalen luxuskonzerns
kehring in der schweiz konzentriert wo
er eine privilegierte kantonale
besteuerung von acht prozent genießt ein
äußerst wettbewerbsfähige satz im
vergleich zu den steuern im rest der
welt
was war die funktion der lti die diese
stratosphärischen gewinne rechtfertigte
eine quelle die der spitze des
unternehmens sehr nahesteht hat mit uns
gesprochen wir durften weder sein
gesicht filmen noch details über ihn
preisgeben wir konnten lediglich unsere
gespräche aufzeichnen und nun davon
berichten fehring erklärt dass die
tessiner niederlassung kommerzielle
tätigkeiten ausübt aber was geschah
wirklich in der lg
grandios es gab große büros in denen den
ganzen tag über rechnungen gedruckt
wurden mehr nicht in der schweiz wurden
logistische und buchhalterische aufgaben
wahrgenommen
gab es oder gibt es wertschöpfungs
positionen
auf keinen fall es gibt überhaupt keine
es gibt nichts kein käufer als jemals im
kino gewesen
haben sie kino gesehen glauben sie kann
im kino repräsentiert die marke ich
meine es ist ein lagerhaus ein hangar
der verkauf und gucci findet in mailand
statt
jährige erklärte aber dass lg eine
kommerzielle plattform sei
ich habe nie gesehen dass bei lg
gehandelt wurde es gab eine
institutionalisierte falschdarstellung
dessen was lg für steuerzwecke tat eine
art betrug und proton in bleiberg eldrup
warum verlässt die kirchen gruppe das
tessin wie haben sie ihren weggang
begründet
der grund im tessin zu bleiben waren die
steuern und nur die steuern mit dem
wegfall der steuervergünstigungen
seitdem die italienische
staatsanwaltschaft gegen sie wegen
steuerhinterziehung ermittelt ergibt der
verbleib im tessin keinen sinn mehr denn
der würde nur betriebliche effizienz und
einen anstieg der kosten bedeuten
in der zwischenzeit hat die lg ihre
mitarbeiter bereits über die verlagerung
nach italien insbesondere nachts novara
informiert wo gucci ein logistikzentrum
und ein werk besitzt das bereits
erweitert wird über seine eigenen
entscheidungen bewahrt das unternehmen
äußerste diskretion
aber es ist uns gelungen mit einigen
mitarbeitern zu sprechen auch in diesem
fall wird niemand zu erkennen sein
das einzige was sie von einem wollen ist
wir mussten eine
geheimhaltungsverpflichtung
unterschreiben sie wollen nicht dass
jemand darüber spricht es geht das
gerücht um dass sie bald mit allem
umziehen werden bei lg sind die gehälter
im vergleich zu den schweizerischen
standards viel niedriger sie liegen
zwischen 3400 und 3800 franken pro monat
wenn man bereits etwas erfahrung hat für
die versetzung nach italien wurde
dasselbe gehalt vorgeschlagen allerdings
mit italienischer besteuerung das heißt
40 prozent weniger
für diejenigen die bereits in italien
leben also fast alle in der firma ist
das in ordnung aber die wenigen
schweizer die dort arbeiten wurden in
die knie gezwungen
wurden dort irgendwelche kommerziellen
aktivitäten durchgeführt oder wichtige
entscheidungen getroffen
das war eine rein logistische und
buchhalterische angelegenheit der rest
ist in campino sicher nie passiert
wir wussten irgendwie das ist für lg
einen etwas fadenscheinigen grund gab in
der schweiz zu sein
- ich dann zum beispiel werden in
campino etiketten gedruckt und an die
lieferanten geschickt man hat uns immer
gesagt dass wir das tun müssen um zu
zeigen dass wir dort an der produktion
beteiligt sind
kennen sie die etiketten die in die
kleidung eingenetzt genau aber sie
sagten sie müssten in der schweiz
gemacht werden und das war's haben die
arbeiter sie gemein ein früher haben wir
das gemacht die büroangestellten ja wir
haben uns abgewechselt um uns um diese
dinge zu kümmern
aber die steuern werden dort bezahlt wo
die hauptaktivitäten stattfinden wie
konnten sie rechtfertigen dass eine
reine logistik niederlassung in campino
gewinne in höhe von 1,7 milliarden
franken erwirtschaftet
diese frage scheint bei gucci im
mittelpunkt der überlegungen gestanden
zu haben denn je größer sie wurde desto
mehr musste sie rechtfertigen dass
wertschöpfende tätigkeiten in der
tessiner niederlassung durchgeführt
wurden wo sie steuern seite die lösung
eine liste von 22 manager die offenbar
im tessin arbeiten und wohnen
es gab die rektoren die sich als unsere
manager ausgaben obwohl sie es in
wirklichkeit nicht waren sie schien ein
büro in campino zu haben aber wir haben
sie nie gesehen die wichtigen männer
waren sicherlich nicht in campino
tatsächlich wurden ihre büros als
besprechungsräume genutzt weil jeder
wusste dass sie nie da waren
sie hatten einen gefälschten wohnsitz um
einen beweis dafür zu liefern dass
wichtige führungsaufgaben in der schweiz
wahrgenommen wurden gleichzeitig stellte
die gruppe diesen managern büro
sekretariat der organisatorische und
operative unterstützung in italien zur
verfügung
wie oft waren dieser manager im tessin
sehr selten fast nie
haben sie jemals wirklich in diesen
wohnungen gelegen
sie haben dort gewohnt die
wohnungsverwaltung wurde den
angestellten überlassen einige
assistenten wurden geschickt um von zeit
zu zeit die post abzuholen und die
stromzähler zu kontrollieren indem sie
ab und zu das licht einschalteten und
die waschmaschinen laufen ließen damit
der stromverbrauch glaubwürdiger war
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie sie aus dieser internen e-mail
ersehen können hat kirin selbst die
versetzungen in die schweiz vorbereitet
und zwar nicht für irgendwelche stellen
sondern für schlüsselpositionen im
unternehmen zum beispiel robert trikots
leiter des marketings diana zanetti
leiterin des merchandising fabio so
stellvertretender leiter des
einzelhandels und mehr leiter der
personalabteilung leiter der
schulabteilung die liste ist lang nach
unseren informationen hat praktisch
keiner von ihnen jemals einen fuß ins
tessin gesetzt für zwei personen ist
jedoch eine sonderbehandlung reserviert
die beiden höchsten gucci
spitzenpositionen patrizio di marco und
marco bizarre
zu unserer rettung haben wir einige sehr
interessante und exklusive dokumente
erhalten es handelt sich um dieselben
dokumente die mediapart erhalten und mit
einem konsortium von
enthüllungsjournalisten geteilt hat
der bis 2014 im amt war war offenbar in
der schweiz ansässig wo er eine
pauschalsteuer regelung genoss
mit dem mietvertrag in der hand sehen
wir uns an wo der gucci präsident wohnte
[Musik]
wissen sie ob patrizio di marco ihr
gewohnt hat
ich kenne ihn nicht der ceo von gucci
haben sie ihm jemals hier gesehen die
marke und nein darf ich ihnen ein bild
zeigen damit sie mir sagen können ob sie
ihnen jemals gesehen haben ja wie lange
leben sie schon hier vier jahre vier
jahre okay ja diese personen kennen sie
sie haben sie ihn jemals gesehen
tut mir leid ich kenne ihn nicht
erleben sie schon lange hier ja
mindestens vier oder fünf jahre
wenn ich ihnen ein bild zeige haben sie
ihn vielleicht schon mal hier gesehen
auf keinen fall sie haben ihn nie
gesehen
[Musik]
die marke wohnte nämlich in der wohnung
die wohnung meiner ist leer seit ich
hier bin es steht also schon seit vier
jahren leer auf jeden fall
die marke wurde hier nie gesehen allein
die prämie für kleidung die die marke
von der firma erhielt war höher als die
jahresmiete dieser wohnung kann man
wirklich glauben dass der präsident von
gucci mit einem jahresumsatz von
mehreren millionen eine 3600 franken
wohnung im ersten stock mit blick auf
die bahn angemietet hatte
[Musik]
die 1500 quadratmeter 44 zimmer fünf
etagen die sich über drei hausnummern
erstrecken mit der adresse in der hand
erreichen wir eine andere art von
aussicht auf die die fenster von dem
akku blicken
[Musik]
wer ist da guten morgen ich wollte
fragen ob es möglich ist mit herrn
patrizio di marco zu sprechen
wer fragt ich bin anna bernasconi die
arbeiten für das schweizer fernsehen
schweizer fernsehen ja nein denn er ist
nicht da
erst nicht zu hause nein er ist nicht zu
hause die marko schrank mit seiner
tochter und seiner frau in dieser villa
auf dem see nicolo in einem der
angesehensten viertel roms zu wohnen
die berühmte ehemalige designerin von
gucci stand tatsächlich am fenster
ich habe mich gefragt ob es möglich ist
mit herrn di marco zu sprechen er ist
nicht zu hause erst nicht zu hause ich
wollte ihnen um einige informationen
bitten über laufende ermittlungen
ich weiß davon nichts ich werde mit
meinem mann darüber sprechen
ich wollte etwas über seinen wohnsitz in
der schweiz erfahren er ist in italien
ansässig
gegenwärtig aber früher war er in der
schweiz ansässig hören sie ich rufe sie
zurück
das ist die informationen die ich haben
wollte
ok danke
[Musik]
dasselbe gilt auch für marco bizarre den
derzeitigen vorsitzenden der gruppe
pauschalpreis wohnsitz im vico morcote
wohin er jedoch nie einen fuss gesetzt
zu haben scheint
[Musik]
ist das nicht der typ der ganz oben
wurmte ihn schon mal jemand gesucht hat
sicherlich haben schon andere
journalisten nach ihm gesucht es ist
schon jemand aus italien gekommen um ihn
zu suchen aber ich habe ihn nie gesehen
was wäre wenn ich ihnen ein bild zeigen
würde wollten sie kurz ich komme
ich habe ihn nie gesehen wer ihn da
jetzt auf dem foto aber nein ich kann
ihnen nicht helfen wie lange leben sie
schon in diesem haus 38 jahre 38 jahre
genau hier ich hätte ihn sehen müssen
zumindest im auto genau aber dass der
ceo von gucci genau hier gewohnt haben
soll
das haben sie auch nicht gewusst ich
habe nie gesehen nein
sowohl gegen bizarre als auch gegen die
marco wird von der staatsanwaltschaft
mailand ermittelt bizzarri arbeitet und
lebt in mailand und zwar seit jahren im
dachgeschoss eines der exklusivsten
gebäude hinter der piazza duomo ich
werde ihnen ein bild zeigen
kennen sie ihn kommt er hierher um
kaffee zu trinken bekam ein paar mal
vorbei
er wohnt hier
injaz noch unterwegs
[Musik]
ich habe bizarren nie im lg gesehen
zumindest soweit ich weiß bizarre sagen
wir mal er ist leicht zu erkennen sie
haben ihn noch nie gesehen nein ich habe
ihn nie gesehen und ich habe noch nie
kollegen sagen hören dass die bizarre
gesehen haben
patrizio di marco nein auch nicht
die marke und bizarre haben den
steuervorteil genutzt und sind nie nach
campino gekommen nun das management das
sind die funktionen mit mehrwert sie
sollten in der schweiz bleiben und ihre
aufgaben dort erfüllen so dass die marge
in der schweiz korrekt zugewiesen würde
welche überprüfungen wurden durchgeführt
als man den beiden super managern die
marke und bizarre das global ist ische
regime gewährte hat man nie eine
unregelmäßigkeit in bezug auf die
herkunft ihrer einkünfte bemerkt die
beitrags- abteilung lehnte ein interview
diesbezüglich ab und berief sich in
einer schriftlichen erklärung auf das
steuergeheimnis
soviel ich weiß haben die behörden das
nie überprüft ja die wahrheit ist dass
das einfach niemand kontrolliert hat
[Musik]
und wie wurde die marke bezahlt es gibt
neue vertrauliche dokumente die
ehemalige nummer eins von gucci erhielt
demnach zusätzlich zu ihrem regulären
gehalt in italien eine zweite vergütung
als berater diese vergütung wurde im
ersten jahr von der lg in campino
gezahlt bis di marco im jahr 2010 die
globalisierung in der schweiz beantragte
allerdings darf man kein schweizer
einkommen haben wenn man diese
steuervorteile erhalten will wie konnte
das problem gelöst werden ganz einfach
durch die übertragung des
beratervertrags von der tessiner lg auf
eine gewisse kastel ein unternehmen mit
sitz in luxemburg eine inoffizielle
vergütung die über eine ihrer offshore
gesellschaften in panama wenn die
international mit einem konto in
singapur erzielt wurde es gibt nur
wenige zweifel daran dass die doppelten
verträge der reguläre in italien und
dieser beratungsvertrag mit dem
luxemburgischen unternehmen kastel
nichts weiter waren als ein spielchen um
einen großen teil der vergütung unter
der hand sein zu können die beiden
verträge wurden am selben tag
unterzeichnet die bonus mitteilungen
wurden immer zu denselben terminen
verschickt und von demselben präsidenten
von kehring kino unterzeichnet das wurde
sogar von di marco zum zeitpunkt der
unterbrechung seiner geschäftsbeziehung
mit der gruppe bestätigt in der er den
vertrag mit castella in bezug auf die
selbe und einzige geschäftsbeziehung
definiert
[Musik]
in nur vier jahren zwischen 2010 und
2014 wurden von castella nach panama
monatlich überweisungen in höhe von
insgesamt 24 millionen franken getätigt
und zwar steuerfrei in der schweiz kam
die marke in den genuss einer minimalen
pauschalsteuer von 130 tausend franken
das heißt er zahlte nur zwei prozent
steuern auf sein tatsächliches einkommen
das ist 20 mal weniger als er in italien
hätte zahlen müssen dasselbe gilt für
bizarre bei einer jährlichen netto
vergütung von 8 millionen entgingen 6
millionen steuern durch luxemburg alles
in allem liegt der vorteil dieses
komplexen verdeckten zahlungssystems
jedoch bei caring selbst das seinen
präsidenten dreimal weniger zahlen
konnte als sie tatsächlich kosteten zum
beispiel für die 24 millionen die
demarco in panama gingen hätte sie 63
millionen mit steuern zahlen müssen eine
beträchtliche ersparnis und eine
möglichkeit die besten manager
einzustellen
wir sind auf dem weg nach luxemburg
einer steueroase im herzen europas wo
das gesetz keine steuern auf im ausland
erwirtschaftete einkünfte vorsieht der
boulevard dollar petrus 124 rastede hat
die gleiche adresse wie ein viel
wichtigeres unternehmen care in
luxemburg es die muttergesellschaft die
unter anderem den lukrativsten zweig der
gruppe kontrolliert die tessiner lg
ein unternehmen mit hunderten von aktien
und milliarden von dividenden hat seinen
sitz bei dieser firma die bereits voll
ausgestattete büros vermietet
[Musik]
ist es möglich mit jemandem von kehring
oder castella zu sprechen
es ist niemand da
niemand ist hier okay darf ich sie
fragen wie viele personen in ihren büros
arbeiten
wie ich ihn schon sagte ohne ihre
genehmigung kann ich keine auskunft
geben
information er ist der direktor des
unternehmens gibt es einen leiter für
die beiden büros
ohne genehmigung kann ich keine weiteren
auskünfte erteilen sie können keine
auskunft geben
sie lassen uns nicht hinein aber nach
dem grundriss zu urteilen den uns eine
quelle innerhalb der gruppe gegeben hat
scheint es sich hierbei ohnehin eher um
eine leere box zu handeln
nicht um die pendler sie hatten weder
angestellte noch ein richtiges büro es
war eine normale sache ein legaler
kasten der milliarden- punkte und mehr
nicht
wir versuchen die adresse des einzigen
luxemburgischen verwalters ausfindig zu
machen der sowohl bei castella als auch
bei care in luxemburg auftaucht
a
[Musik]
aber das ist alles was wir finden
konnten nur ein briefkasten
sie sind herr ackermann
tja jahren sie persönlich und direkt an
der unterstützung und verschleierung der
steuer position von herrn di marco
beteiligt
ich will nicht mit ihnen reden so wie
bei bizarre
[Musik]
lag er in luxemburg stützt sein
steuersystem auf die tessiner
niederlassung der lg kastellan dient der
diskreten entlohnung von managern die
als global iste nimmt es ihnen keine
einkünfte in der schweiz beziehen können
es scheint ein gesamtpaket zu sein dass
gehring angeboten wird um so viel wie
möglich zu sparen und das mit dem tessin
verflochten ist
so wurde eigentlich das konto der
luxemburgischen gesellschaft eröffnet
und eingerichtet
die luxemburgische firma castella
benutzte ein konto der credit suisse in
lugano
das geld kam von der lg luxemburg war so
strukturiert dass es der schweiz die
stirn bieten konnte der steuer fox sitzt
im tessin lament der fiskal
gehen wir zurück in die tessiner sonne
im folgenden dürfen wir seine stimme
zwar nicht preisgeben aber wir können
die dialoge genauso wieder geben wie sie
stattgefunden haben ein direkter zeuge
der bisher noch nie gesprochen hat hat
sich bereit erklärt sich mit uns zu
treffen und uns zu verraten wie die
steuer architektur des unternehmens in
der schweiz aufgebaut und umgesetzt
wurde
wenn man der erste steuerzahler des
kantons ist eine bekannte marke dann
erlaubt einem sein status dinge die
andere nicht erlaubt sind wenn man einen
gast in der kaiser suite im hotel hat
verwöhnt man ihn nicht wahr nun sie
waren gäste in der kaiser suite sie
wurden verwöhnt uns man hörte ihnen zu
die person die die steuerlichen
positionen der gucci manager und die
steuerstruktur des unternehmens
aufgebaut hat ist ein treuhänder mit
einem büro in lugano vom ersten tag an
im verwaltungsrat von gucci in campino
register die gustav schäfer die pro kopf
dieses zahlungssystems für die manager
war die solar die um die tatsache zu
umgehen dass die global ist ische
pauschalregelung durch den nachweis von
auslands einkünften erreicht wird hat la
die das system in luxemburg ausgeheckt
damit die manager die marke und bizarr
die jeweils der global ist ischen
regelung nach weniger steuern zahlen
konnten er war persönlich an der
erlangung dieser pauschalsteuer regelung
für die beiden ceos beteiligt audi ist
das große gehirn der strukturen der
schweiz und bei alldem war gut sie
definitiv der größte kunde der firma
der treuhänder antwortete uns auch nach
mehrmaligem nachfragen nicht selbst wenn
wir persönlich in sein büro gingen wurde
uns gesagt wir sollten unsere fragen an
das französische büro von kehring
stellen
wie kam gut die ursprünglich noch
campino
die
vatikanbank ladens der sinologie und
sänger damals finanzdirektor der gucci
gruppe hatten bei coopers & lybrand
zusammen gearbeitet und waren durch eine
tiefe freundschaft verbunden la diva
gemeindevertretern campino
audi stellt für verschiedenen
unternehmen der kirch-gruppe rund 250000
franken pro jahr in rechnung er war aber
auch teilzeit angestellter der kirche in
luxembourg euro' financial investments
niederlassung mit einem festgehalt von
130 tausend franken ja bei alg ii war es
also praktisch einen zusätzlichen
mitarbeiter auf der lohnliste zu haben
noch dazu einen schweizer um das
unternehmen glaubwürdig zu machen um den
anschein einer schweizer mehrheit in den
verwaltungsräten zu erwecken wurden
weitere in der schweiz ansässige
personen eingestellt darunter mehrere
berater
neben lg taucht der name des tessiner
treuhänders auch in den aufsichtsräten
mehrerer tessiner modeunternehmen wie
abercrombie tom ford und loro piana auf
die firma war auch an der gesellschaft
beteiligt dc cover besitzt eine
schuhmarke die von den italienischen
finanzbehörden wegen steuerhinterziehung
beschlagnahmt wurde mit einem eigentümer
der einen scheinwohnsitz im tessin hatte
und im lg verwaltungsrat sass seit der
ankunft von gucci im tessin auch der
berater paolo bruni er ist mitarbeiter
der anwaltskanzlei mazzoni und schwager
von marina masoni staatsrätin und
direktorin des wirtschafts und
finanzministeriums zur zeit der
ansiedlung von gucci im tessin und heute
präsident von ticino moda die
führungskräfte von gucci und die gesamte
gruppe die im laufe der jahre ein und
aus gegangen ist kamen alle bei der
firma sony vorbei um ihre unterschrift
zu leisten alle urkunden und
rechtsberatungen wurden dort
durchgeführt
[Musik]
wir haben einen interessanten austausch
von internen e-mails erhalten die unter
den topmanagern von care in einem der
wichtigsten börsennotierten unternehmen
in frankreich verschickt wurden es wird
geschätzt dass sich die über die
tessiner niederlassung begangene
steuerhinterziehung auf 2,5 milliarden
euro beläuft der größte fall von
steuerbetrug eines unternehmens in
frankreich jemals was die kehring
direktoren in aufruhr versetzt ist eine
frage des französischen senats der 2012
und 2013 zwei mal wegen
steuerhinterziehung ermittelt hat
bezahlt das unternehmen mitarbeiter im
ausland wo sie keine tätigkeiten ausüben
die fonds seien sie vorsichtig schrieben
sie und versuchten dann in mehreren
anläufen sich auf eine möglichst
konkrete formel zu einigen um den senat
damit von ihrer ehrlichkeit zu
überzeugen
tatsächlich hat gehring das für die
bezahlung der manager eingerichtete
offshore system verschwiegen und zwei
mal falsche angaben gemacht verfasser
des fragebogens ist der senator der
französischen republik eric bock leiter
der untersuchungsausschüsse zur
steuerhinterziehung
gehring gruppe der familie kino hat den
senat zwei mal belogen ich möchte ihnen
einige dokumente und e mails zeigen die
einige kehring führungskräfte balu und
du play geschrieben haben die sich an
sie wenden auf ihre anfrage
seien sie auf der hut zaubere version
der antwort auf den senats fragebogen
das ist unglaublich es ist ernst das
parlament kann nicht bis zu diesem
zeitpunkt verachtet werden das ist
absolut inakzeptabel der senat kann in
dieser angelegenheit nicht schweigen und
wenn es ein nachspiel gibt dann muss es
durch die justiz gehen
steuerhinterziehung ist schwerwiegend
weil sie den staatshaushalt gefährdet
das geld wird in schulen krankenhäusern
gemeinden dem was die gesellschaft
verbessern würde vorenthalten man sagt
uns dass kein geld da sei und das ist
große gruppen wie diese gibt die
frankreich jedes jahr 80 milliarden euro
verlieren ließen
80 milliarden ist das jährliche defizit
unseres landes das ist völlig
inakzeptabel ist gefährdet unsere
gesellschaft ist gefährdet die
solidarität auch die demokratie es sind
nicht die konzerne die das steuergesetz
machen es ist das parlament es ist die
politik mit einem großen p die über das
steuerrecht entscheidet diese großen
konzerne werden morgen die welt anführen
indem sie sich dafür entscheiden dort
steuern zu zahlen wo sie wollen und
natürlich dort wo es viel billiger ist
das ist definitiv inakzeptabel ein
unternehmen ist teil der gesellschaft es
ist ein element es ist dazu da
bedürfnisse zu befriedigen waren zu
produzieren dienstleistungen anzubieten
die gesellschaft voranzubringen es ist
nicht nur eine maschine die geld
produziert und geld verdient es ist auch
eine verantwortung gegenüber dem gebiet
und der gesellschaft
die menschen können diese geschichte von
steuerhinterziehung nicht mehr ertragen
auf kundgebungen hört man regelmäßig von
steuerparadiesen und steuerhinterziehung
und die menschen wollen dass wir dieses
problem wirklich an der wurzel packen
drei fussballfelder gross
330.000 kubikmeter ohne logos oder
schilder das ist die erweiterung des
gucci lagers in sant antoni no was ist
die funktion des größten gebäudes im
kanton tessin jeden tag 365 tage im jahr
kommen 50.000 waren die bereits für die
gesamte produktion von gucci und anderen
kehring marken fertiggestellt wurden mit
lastwagen in diesem lager an werden
eingelagert in kisten gepackt und
verlassen es wieder was passiert
eigentlich in dieser kurzen zeit in
tessin die rechnungen werden gedruckt
und luxus produkte made in italy werden
vom tessin aus in die ganze welt
verkauft
indem man auch auf die
verrechnungspreise spielt den verkauf
der ware die von den lieferanten zu
einem preis nahe den produktionspreis
kommt und zu einem preis nachdem der
designer leben ausgeht bedeutet das für
luxusgüter riesige menschen und
ermöglicht so die realisierung
sensationelle gewinne im tessin aber ist
die logistik eine funktion die sie
rechtfertigt ihr job ist im grunde die
logistik ja das ist richtig sind die
gehälter gut und nicht so ganz also
teils teils und sind sie hier ansässig
nein in italien sie sind italiener in
italien darf ich sie fragen wie groß die
gehalts spanne ist sie meinen je nachdem
wie viele stunden wir leisten sie werden
nach stunden bezahlt ja bei der agentur
wird nach stunden abgerechnet und der
stundensatz liegt bei so in etwa wir
bekommen etwa 17 franken pro stunde 17
franken pro stunde ja es ist alles auf
einer lüge aufgebaut wo denn im grunde
handelt es sich um ein unternehmen das
sich mit logistik befasst während man
viele jahre lang vor gab es sei ein
unternehmen das alle seine wichtigsten
funktionen hier konzentriert hat
logistik ist keine hauptfunktion
können sie erklären welche funktionen
die logistik hat warum kommt die
logistik in die schweiz
ihre präsenz in der schweiz zu
rechtfertigen wären die ansiedlung der
logistik in der schweiz war notwendig um
die rolle von lg zu etablieren und zu
rechtfertigen gehring hat sich bisher
immer für den warentransport durch die
schweiz eingesetzt die logistik in der
schweiz ist ein extra schritt aus
steuerlichen gründen und so ein extra
schritt ist immer schädlich es gehen
liefert arge verloren es gibt eine
verdopplung der kosten und das sind
alles kosten die von einem steuer
kreislauf diktiert werden den wir sehr
wohl vermeiden könnten wenn die schweiz
die aus betrieblicher sicht ineffizient
ist keinen steuervorteil mehr zulässt
nun dann ist es sinnlos
die vista operativer nun constantini
anke bumann teil die fiskale
warum beschloss die gruppe ihr eigenes
lager in sant antoni no einzurichten
falls die gruppe beschlossen ihr eigenes
lagerhaus zu bauen suchte sie lange nach
einem grundstück dieser größe die gruppe
wollte sich ursprünglich nicht in sant
antoni niederlassen sondern auf einem
grundstücken näher an der italienischen
grenze es machte keinen sinn die
lastwagen in das super tenere fahren zu
lassen um eine fahrt zu unternehmen die
ohnehin nutzlos und teuer war zudem
handelte es sich um ein problematisches
grundstück das verbessert werden musste
außerdem war der multiplikator in sant
antoni no vor der ankunft von gucci hoch
wir kommen nicht mit einem so hohen
multiplikator aber mit unserem projekt
werden sie ihn senken können weil wir
ihnen eine menge geld geben werden es
gab eine diskussion mit vita über die
präventive senkung des multiplikators
und er war dem unternehmen eine große
hilfe der multiplikator aus dem jahr
2010 vier jahre vor der ankunft von
gucci zu beginn der verhandlungen wurde
schrittweise um 15 punkte gesenkt und
fiel auf 65 prozent im jahr 2014 dem
jahr in dem das lager gebaut wurde der
multiplikator soll nun wieder steigen da
der konzern die stadt verlässt und seine
an die stadtverwaltung gezahlten
einnahmen um mehr als die hälfte sinken
wie rechtfertigen sie diese änderung der
einnahmen
sie begründen dies damit dass die
gewinne die bisher vollständig im tessin
besteuert wurden nun aufgrund einer
unternehmenspolitischen regelung dort
besteuert werden wo das produkt
hergestellt wird und dort wo es
weiterverarbeitet wird
er ist das prestige ein derartiges
lagerhaus an ihrem gebiet zu haben
erinnern sie zunächst einmal möchte ich
sagen dass die bezeichnung lagerhaus für
diese anlage die im wert von mehreren
zehn millionen schweizer franken gebaut
wurde etwas zu kurz gegriffen ist die
lastwagen mit den waren kommen da
jedenfalls an die waren kommen an und
von dort aus werden sie sortiert
die meisten menschen die dort arbeiten
sind lagerarbeiter
im größten teil
welche vorteile bringt und brachte
dieses unternehmen dem gebiet
im allgemeinen brachte es dem gebiet vor
allem den vorteil einen großen teil des
industriegebiets und der
wirtschaftlichen ressourcen neu zu
entwickeln ressourcen die dann in form
von dienstleistungen an die bevölkerung
weitergegeben werden
und was ist mit den arbeitsplätzen
soweit wir wissen gibt es 200
arbeitsplätze von denen ein kleiner teil
von einheimischen besetzt ist
haben sie eine ahnung welche art von
gehältern im durchschnitt angeboten
werden
ich habe keine ahnung wie viel sie
angeboten haben
macht ihnen die vorstellung angst dass
das unternehmen eines tages für immer
weg gehen und dieses gebäude leer stehen
könnte
diese gruppen können wie wir wissen
gegen sich reformieren und umziehen ohne
jemanden fragen zu müssen denn es ist
ihre entscheidung das zu tun
[Musik]
die neue anlage in dem lager in riazzino
wurde offiziell von lg angekündigt aber
ist es wirklich eine erweiterung oder
ist es nur eine bestätigung dessen dass
sie sich nur in kleineren lagern
organisieren um die logistik komplett
abzubauen
maximale diskretion das von dem
unternehmen das seit jahren der größte
steuerzahler im kanton ist scheint man
nicht einmal den namen aussprechen zu
können
wir wollten uns lediglich danach
erkundigen ob das lager hier in der
hauptsitz ist
ich weiß nichts darüber ich weiß
wirklich nicht
was sie haben einen pullover auf dem
luxusgüter logistik steht ein guter
freund von mir hat ihn mir geschenkt
aber sie arbeiten hier ja aber nicht für
das unternehmen das sie gerade erwähnt
haben luxusgüter richtig ja ich arbeite
nicht für sie wir können dazu nichts
sagen tut mir leid aber für wen arbeiten
sie
ich habe keine ahnung ich bin nicht von
hier
ich finde es seltsam dass man nicht
sagen kann für wie man arbeitet das
haben sie uns gesagt nichts zu sagen ja
das haben sie uns gesagt
das unternehmen hat sich nicht zu dem
möglichen änderungen in der logistik
geäußert sicher ist dass in tessin
vorerst nur lastwagen und kisten
verbleiben ohne den vorteil von
steuereinnahmen
[Musik]